brace yourselves Kamala Harris has a new
job no she's not stepping down as VP
Biden's tapping her to save Humanity
from the robots today she's rubbing
elbows with top Tech CEOs about the
risks of artificial intelligence let's
hope komala is excited about this as she
has other topics
does it love a yellow school bus right
can you raise your hand
your Hail the yellow school bus right
a lot of things in the context of a Venn
diagram I love Venn diagrams always ask
is there a Venn diagram for this I'm
I'm tying the unknown you're gonna
literally see the craters on the moon
with your own eyes
big takeaway from the meeting is that AI
could infringe on civil rights and erode
public trust and faith in democracy Dana
where was Joe Biden during this big
meeting with these AI guys he stopped by
oh he did yeah he stopped by to just
just monitor say hi I was thinking about
you remember in school when the
principal would come into your class and
stand in the back and you know your
teacher was being watched and then
everyone would try to be on their best
behavior for a minute I think that's
what happened I'm just curious are these
the same CEOs that she talked to about
expanding their operations in Latin
America to help prevent immigration that
never happened I wondered I wonder what
those CEOs were thinking maybe not the
same ones who knows I love the story
about her taking over because it reminds
me of bringing out the child actors like
we just saw in the NASA video
here's the thing what made Biden think
this is a good idea because what in her
track record has said this is a great
very serious problem that she can help
solve it she didn't immigration that was
not going to be it
voting rights not it now they do give
her a lot of credit on abortion although
I sort of feel like that is already
self-perpetuating and you don't really
need to do too much on that to get
Democrats to vote along those lines
I think that with AI
I'm not sure how Washington's going to
help
I I would like to think that Washington
could help but I'm pretty sure that all
of us are just going to be slaves to the
robots and then we'll all be unified and
not be polarized anymore Greg the
president said he wanted to have Kamala
handle this because he wanted to elevate
her profile yes how nice of him it's how
soon before she makes it about race
right oh she did she did this is going
to affect civil rights yeah it's like I
I don't yeah I guess that's that I kind
of saw that as civil rights for
everybody but maybe I don't know I think
um I I can Wing a lot of topics I can't
Wing Ai and she Wings everything and the
fact is artificial intelligence is too
important a threat and a challenge to
our government to go out and get drunk
the night before then sleep in and then
wing it which is what I did for
everything it's not a quarterly report
on travel expenses it's a freaking I
mean it's really important it's insane
this is what every major intellect
describes as the largest serious
existential threat of our time and they
appoint the least thoughtful person
who's arrogant enough to think that she
doesn't have to prepare for anything I
don't even know if she can even Define
it maybe she watched an episode of Lost
in Space and and followed Robbie the
robot but uh I don't know man the scary
thing is uh what you said there's no one
in the white house who could work with
this issue remember the social media
hearings they had the guy from Facebook
and like you they didn't even know what
they didn't know what they were talking
about they're too old to talk about this
stuff and she's just having a great time
she doesn't care I mean if Biden can't
understand it Kamala can't understand it
Kaylee who would you put there in charge
of this meeting I mean I can't
understand it but like the Venn diagram
loving Veep like she's got it no no one
believes that even Elon Musk like one of
the most brilliant people says hey we
got to put a pause to this till we get
our hands around it I mean I learned on
on outnumbered today that they can
interpret thoughts apparently some AI
like read your thoughts they can read my
mind yeah read your mind like imagine if
I knew
true
right imagine this Administration like
being able to read American people's
thoughts like very scary yeah they'd
resign if they could you know what we
were thinking how do you interpret this
I mean this is a you know big step up in
her portfolio
so I actually thought that this was just
getting to do this meeting and that it
wasn't a portfolio change of any kind oh
she's not AI Czar that's my
understanding okay it was a thing
for today to do this and to convey the
administration's concerns obviously
about already backing away from it yeah
right no but I maybe I'm I could be
wrong about this but that that was my
input so when the robots start killing
us Biden can blame Kamala she was in
charge
you know
I don't think it was that serious I
think it was a meeting I think either he
had a scheduled conflict or she said I
would like to do this and he said that's
completely
it's been seen in days well you know the
price is right is on at 11 A.M and then
he has his nap but it is a big deal
right but why shouldn't the vice
president I get it that you want to mock
her but she still is the vice president
why shouldn't she be involved in this
and she has done a good job on really
serious issues I mean if you saw her at
the Munich security conference she did a
wonderful job representing U.S and
frankly Democratic morals and values all
across the world in our defense of
either supporting zelinski and what's
going on there so yeah I get it it's
like
absolutely I got this t-shirt you
crushed Munich and it has caramela on it
all right well your garden I'm still
curious about why Joe isn't in the
meeting hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now